[Music]
Mexican holiday Cinco DeMayo is coming
up this Sunday but with a sluggish
economy people might be electing to go
wild this year
don't you worry our prop master built
all was pumped with some do-it-yourself
ways to really enjoy this festive
holiday bill take two frisbees pour some
cheese on them boom quesadilla these are
more expensive than just corn tortillas
the most inexpensive meal in the history
of the world now go out and buy to $9.99
rizz B's here's bill with this first tip
take a tube sock stuff it with ground
beef boom burrito
[Music]
these are not saving money you know
expensive tortillas are take some
avocados smashing with a mini fridge
boom guacamole
huge money saver now it's just making
things crazily take some chloroform
breathe it in boom siesta
[Music]
[Laughter]
take a bowl of beans stick a vibrator in
them boom Mexican jumping beans take a
can of Beefaroni pour it down the back
of your pants boom Montezuma's Revenge
tired of expensive diarrhea you guys
have lost your minds
oh my god you made bail Porter's pants I
love it when there's no luck we're gonna
do this look at you good Cinco de Mayo
and makes no sense the high cost of naps
got you down all right
[Laughter]
[Music]